PROFESSOR: It's sort of a
little bit thrown in between.
What you've done is
you've essentially
just finished doing the whole
section on energy models.
Remember we started all
the way in the beginning
with empirical potential models
when doing [INAUDIBLE] method,
and then Professor Marzari
did quantum mechanics.
A lot of the rest of
what you're going to see
is on particular
simulation techniques
that bring in dynamics and
temperature into the problem.
What I wanted to do
with this lecture
is sort of tell you
the story of my life.
You work so hard on
doing quantum mechanics,
and you do it well.
And you come up with all
these beautiful things
you calculate in energies, and
you give a whole talk on that.
And there'll always
be some smarty pants
in the audience that will get
up at the end of your talk
and say, you know.
But all your calculations
are at 0 temperature.
And so basically with
one slight comment,
they basically wipe your
whole talk off the table.
And half of the room
suddenly sort of thinks
that you're just kind
of a funny curiosity.
So what I want to do
here today is teach you
sort of to what extent
does temperature matter.
So first of all, when are
zero-temperature calculations
relevant?
When are they extremely good
to mimic the real world, which
is non-zero temperature?
When is it so so?
And when do you absolutely need
to take temperature explicitly
into account?
And then the next step
is, how do you do that?
Now I will give you
hints of that today
already-- how you do that.
But later the rest of the
course is essentially on that.
So to learn to push
the right buttons here.
Huh?
So again these are the
objectives of today.
And maybe what I'll add a
little is sort of, why is it
so hard to include temperature?
People who don't do
simulations often
think that, why don't you
just turn on that button?
There's this button temperature.
And why don't you turn it on?
Why don't you just do
zero-temperature calculation?
So but if you look at
the Kohn-Sham equations,
obviously, there is
no temperature in it.
OK?
So this is not like some
physical approximation
that we can decide
to turn on or off.
It turns out if you want to
deal with temperature effects,
there's a whole lot
of work you have
to do on top of your
energy calculation.
You can see why that is.
Essentially what you're
doing with quantum
mechanics is you're calculating
the ground state energy.
Now essentially
temperature is no more--
when you're at
non-zero temperature,
it's exactly making the same
statement in saying, you know,
I've put energy in my system
to make it be above the ground
state energy.
So at non-zero temperature,
you've pumped in extra energy.
There's many ways
you can see that.
You can just see that from
the derivative of the energy
with temperature, which is the
heat capacity, which is always
positive, which means
as soon as you raise
the temperature from 0,
the energy has gone up
above your ground state energy.
So where is that energy?
This is going to be the key
question when you want to deal
with temperature simulation.
First of all, let me tell you
there is no generic temperature
simulation.
There is no one way to
include temperature,
and this is going to be
an important message.
And the reason is
that extra energy goes
into excitations of the system.
OK?
It goes into, you know,
displacements of atoms,
phonon modes.
It can go into
electronic excitations.
It can go into defects.
And you will have
to explicitly choose
which of these excitations
you include in your modeling.
So every time you do a
temperature modeling, most
of the time, what that
means is that you're
going to have selected a series
of excitations in which you
allow energy to be pumped
in for temperature,
but that means you will
have excluded other ones.
There is essentially
no technique
that allows for all
possible excitations
as you have in nature.
So we will often go
back between sort
of the measure of
temperature as temperature,
or simply the measure
of excitation energy
as temperature.
Essentially, the
amount of energy
you're above the ground
state can be used
as a measure of temperature.
And let me show that.
Here's a little bit of
statistical mechanics
in a sort of classical picture.
Some of you may have
seen this already.
Some of you may have not.
If you haven't seen this,
just try to maybe just get
the general idea.
You know, in
classical mechanics,
you often write the Hamiltonian,
which is essentially
what's used to derive
your equation of motion
in generalized coordinates qi
and generalized momenta pi.
And the reason you have
both is, of course,
because you have potential
and kinetic energy.
The momentum will represent
the kinetic energy,
and the generalized
coordinates will
represent the potential energy.
So the reason they're
generalized coordinates
is because they don't
just-- they're not just
coordinates of atoms.
They could be
linear combinations
of those coordinates
of atoms, for example.
So the Hamiltonian
is then essentially
the potential energy as
a function of the two
and the kinetic energy
as a function of the two.
In general, the kinetic energy
can be a function of both,
and the potential energy
can be a function of both
although normally you find
that internal energy is only
a function of the
generalized coordinates.
And the kinetic energy
is only a function
of the generalized momentum.
The equipartition theorem
essentially tells you
the definition of temperature.
It tells you that the
expectation value of, say,
the momentum times the
Hamiltonian derivative
with that momentum, that
the expectation value is
kT and the same
for the expectation
value with the
generalized coordinate.
And sort of you can kind of see
a little bit what that means.
The derivative of a
Hamiltonian, which you can think
of as an energy function--
the derivative of a
Hamiltonian with respect
to a coordinate, that's
a force typically.
So this is a force
times a coordinate,
and here you have a force
times the displacement.
So these are energy terms.
These are work and power terms.
The expectation value is the
time average expectation value.
This is the general statement
not for quadratic Hamiltonians.
You'll see we get a more
useful and more common result.
So a quadratic
Hamilton is one where
the Hamilton, the energy
terms, are second powers
of the coordinates.
And this is what
you very often get.
If you have a velocity, then
your kinetic energy is mv
squared over 2-- so the
quadratic in the momentum
the momentum being mv.
If you had coordinates that
move in a harmonic potential,
a quadratic potential if
two things were connected
by a spring, an ideal
harmonic spring,
then the potential energy would
be quadratic in the spring
distance.
OK?
So in that case, you
can work through it
because then the derivative of
the Hamiltonian with respect
to any of these things is
linear in the coordinates.
So since you multiply,
you get something that's
quadratic in the coordinates.
So then what you get is that
essentially up to some constant
the average of the
squared coordinate,
or squared momentum,
is kT over 2.
So what that's
really telling you
is that every degree
of freedom you think
of-- every qi, every pi
is a degree of freedom.
Every degree of freedom contains
a thermal energy equivalent
to kT over 2.
And this is sort of an
interesting statement
because it doesn't tell you
anything about the stiffness
of that degree of freedom.
In principle, if I have
even a stiff spring
or a loose spring--
losing my words this morning--
have the same thermal energy
at a given temperature.
Even though they will
vibrate very differently,
the stiff spring
will not vibrate
a lot, which will vibrate
with small amplitude
but at high frequency.
OK?
And the soft spring will
vibrate at low frequency
with lower amplitude.
But so they all have the
same degrees of freedom.
And so this is how you
can calculate, like,
typical heat capacity.
So if you think of n atoms,
how many degrees of freedom
do you have if with
n atoms you have
three coordinates for atom?
So you have three
degrees of freedom
for the coordinate-wise.
You have three
velocity components.
So you have 3n components
from the velocity,
so you have 6n
degrees of freedom.
So what's the thermal energy
when you have 3n atom?
It's 6 nkT over 2 of them.
So it's 3nkT.
And that's the sort
of classical result
you find that the
thermal energy is 3 nkT--
so what's the heat capacity?
It's 3 times k.
And those of you
who've taken thermal
from me, that's the
law of Dulong-Petit
if you remember that.
It comes straight out of
the equipartition theorem.
There's some subtleties.
This statement is only
true when the energy
depends quadratically
on these coordinates.
So people often
remember the statement.
But now where it comes from?
So if your particle is moving
in a non-harmonic, which you'll
typically see if you
start getting oscillations
far from equilibrium--
around equilibrium,
you tend to be
quadratic in a potential
if you go far away to see
non-quadratic behavior.
This will not be true anymore--
and the same thing
for the velocities.
But there's maybe a
more important subtlety.
This is only true--
what we did now is
classical mechanics,
and the results we get are only
true for degrees of freedom
for which there's enough
energy for them to be excited.
And what do I mean with that?
We know from quantum
statistical mechanics
that the states are
degrees of freedom,
and the energy associated
with them is quantized.
So you cannot move from the
ground state continuously
in excitations.
The first excitation
from the ground state
takes a finite amount of energy.
If you live on a temperature
scale for which you don't have
enough energy to get
that first excitation,
then the system
will essentially not
be excited in those
degrees of freedom.
And they will not contribute
to the thermal energy.
OK?
So if you live at,
say, room temperature,
that's 25 millielectron volts,
and your first excitation
is 1 electron volt,
that degree of freedom
is not going to contribute to
the internal energy or the heat
capacity.
OK?
So that's a bit of a
subtlety that shows up
with the equipartition theorem.
And this is if
you remember why--
so the classic the
classical heat capacity
is 3 kb from what
I've shown you before.
But if you remember this is
why if you plotted versus
temperature, the heat capacity,
it is 3 kb at high temperature.
But then it sort of drops
off to low temperature
because essentially the
heat capacity coming
from the atomic
displacements gets
frozen out because the atomic
displacements are quantized.
They're not continuous in
a quantum mechanic sense.
So in some sense this is
the subtext of the lecture.
And if you're going to
do a non-zero temperature
simulation, I assume you
do that to get a certain--
see a certain behavior or
calculate a certain property.
You need to understand
right away which excitations
you're going to sample.
Which excitations that are going
to be present in your model
to allow for the extra energy
that comes with temperature?
So that means that you
have to understand first
the excitations that are
relevant for the behavior
you want to study, and
you have to understand
how they store energy.
And I'll give you
some examples of that.
I'll try to make that a
lot clearer in a second.
So, you know, how do
materials store energy?
Here's some possible
excitation mechanisms.
Electronic.
You know, you're calculating
quantum mechanics not only
the atomic ground state--
you know, you relax
all the atoms.
I think you've done
that in the lab
now to the lowest
energy position.
But you always, always find
the electronic ground states,
but at non-zero
temperature you can
have electronic excitations.
You know, think of electron
excitations across a bandgap
as, if the bandgap's large, it's
a small number of electrons.
But if you have a metal, you
know, then the Fermi level
is in the density of states.
There's no gap there.
So you can have,
at any temperature,
excitations of electrons
across that gap.
And I'll show you later
some actual results
to see how important or
not important that can be.
Vibrational are
the obvious ones.
So that's the one
you always think of.
If you raise the temperature,
what do atoms do?
They move kind of.
They start vibrating.
That's kind of the
typical obvious one.
I know everybody's staring at
this picture of springs going.
It's amazing how we
can hypnotize you.
And then there's of course
more subtle excitations.
If you have a compound, an
ordered system where atoms are,
say, ordered in a
pattern, they might
start inter-changing positions.
So we think of these as
configurational excitations.
The equivalent in
polymers is that you
change the confirmation
of polymers
at elevated temperature.
So what kind of
changes might you
want to look at where you
think you need temperature?
There's obviously
things-- obvious one.
Crystal structure changes.
Sometimes you want
to calculate what
the structures of
material, and it's already
a really hard problem
to do that at 0 Kelvin
because it's a sort of
non-local optimization problem.
If I give you gold,
silver, and fluorine,
and I tell you I'd throw
these together in a bucket,
what will they form?
I don't even know they
will form a solid,
but let's say they did.
That's a global
optimization problem.
You cannot solve that by local
optimization minimizing forces
on coordinates.
OK?
So the zero-temperature
problem is already hard enough.
But then I tell you, well, the
crystals structures we know
can change as a
function of temperature.
So now not only do you have
to find the ground state,
but you have to
figure out what are
the sort of entropic factors,
the excitations, that
make free energy different from
energy and therefore structures
change as a function
of temperature.
Chemistry can be very important.
Changes in chemistry as a
function of temperature-- this
is sort of an often
overlooked one.
When you work with
materials, many of them
are open systems
to the environment.
A perfect example
is an oxide if you
take an oxide
that's by definition
open to the environment
because it can exchange oxygen
in the environment.
So most people who
work with ceramics
know that, if you heat them high
enough, they start reducing.
So they start losing
oxygen. So this
is one of these things where
it's an obvious temperature
effect.
Properties.
You know, there's
obvious properties--
electrical conductivity,
thermal conductivity.
All these things are very
temperature dependent.
They actually, in some
cases, have trivial forms
at low temperature.
And then there's sort of
trivial properties-- volume.
Maybe you want to know what
the thermal expansion does?
So I'll go through
several of these.
And the reason I do
it is because there's
no unique method
to do all of these.
So depending on what
it is you're after,
you're going to have to
come up with different signs
and a different toolset.
So I thought I'd give you a
very straightforward example.
Here's a work done I
think by Andrew Huang--
I don't remember-- at Livermore
showing the temperature
dependence of the bulk
modulus of copper.
And what you see here is
three different results.
So that's the LDA result.
And you know what that is-- the
local density approximation.
The GGA result, notice that
it's as you kind of expected
and we discussed
a little-- softer.
And then the experiment
is the green points.
The experiment is
right in between.
So let's say somebody asked you
to calculate the temperature
dependence of the bulk
modulus of the material.
How do you turn
temperature on here?
In essence, what
I'm asking you is
what is the essential physics
that makes the bulk modulus
temperature dependent?
Because if you know that,
then that's the physics
you want to include.
OK?
So you could say,
well, you know,
I'm going to do
this brute force.
I'll do a big molecular
dynamics simulation.
And after this we'll start
molecular dynamics in a class.
And that's definitely a way that
you would get the temperature
dependence of the bulk modulus.
But in some cases, you
can do this much faster
if you're sort of smart about
what the physics is that going.
Let me sort of show you
what the question really is.
The bulk modulus is defined
as the second derivative
of the energy with
respect to volume,
but there's some
subtleties there.
Correctly, it's the second
derivative of the free energy
with respect to volume.
Now you have to evaluate
that derivative somewhere.
You evaluate it at the
equilibrium lattice constant.
OK?
So what do you do when
you do the bulk modulus
at 0 temperature?
What we do is you don't
have the free energy.
Well, the energy is
equal to the free energy
at zero-temperature.
So first of all, you take
the second derivative
of the energy not
of the free energy.
And you don't take it at the
finite-temperature lattice
parameter.
You take it at the
zero-temperature lattice
parameter.
OK?
So we have two sources of error.
And one is they both require
a different solution.
We use energy to
calculate the bulk modulus
at zero-temperature
rather than free energy.
And we use the zero-temperature
lattice parameter rather than
the finite-temperature
lattice parameter.
So the question is, which of
the two is the dominant one?
Or do they sort of--
if you're out of luck,
they both kind of contribute
the same effect, which means you
need to deal with both of them.
Well, that's what sort
of this picture tells us.
What these two lines are is the
bulk modulus artificially taken
at different lattice constants.
And the way you can do
that is you can actually
plot either energy or free
energy as a function of lattice
parameter, and then
in the minimum,
you have a bulk modulus.
It's the curvature
there, but you could also
get it, the curvature, at
other lattice parameters.
And so you'd get
the bulk modulus
as a function of the
lattice parameter.
And it's done in two ways.
It's done by taking
derivatives of the energy.
That's the purple curve here.
And then the brown
one is done by taking
derivatives of the free energy.
So what do you see?
Well, what you see is that
neglecting the entropy
in the second derivative
is not a big deal because,
at a given lattice
parameter, whether I
take the derivative of the
energy or the three energy
is not a big error.
Where does the biggest
error come from?
It's that if I'm not at the
right lattice parameter.
So what causes the temperature
dependence of the bulk
modulus is the fact that
the lattice parameter
changes with temperature.
OK?
And see now we've made a
really big step forward,
because if we're willing to
work on the data approximation,
then all we need to do is
get the lattice parameter
as a function of temperature
and just calculate
the curvature of the energy
in that lattice parameter.
Now we have a good
approximation--
the bulk modulus.
Now this is a slightly
recursive problem
because, I'm going to
show in a second that,
if you want the
lattice parameter,
if you want to
predict it, you'll
actually need the entropy.
So you need the
free energy anyway.
But sometimes you have
the lattice parameter.
OK?
Sometimes you just,
you know, want
the bulk modulus, say, at the
experimental lattice parameter
you've measured it.
Now what I'm saying is, if
you have that information,
there is no need to do
a temperature-dependent
simulation.
You just take the curvature
in that lattice parameter,
and you're done.
So the physics here that
drives the temperature
dependence of the bulk modulus
is the thermal expansion.
So here's sort of a
zoology of numbers
that I've taken
out of this paper.
You know, I am a strong
believer in numbers.
That's why I feed you so many.
I believe that science
without numbers is out there.
And so I'm sorry if that sort
of bores you with numbers.
But I do believe from
actually looking at the facts,
you separate fact from reality.
No-- fiction from reality.
So here's sort of
three different options
for calculating
the bulk modulus.
So here the bulk
modulus is calculated
at the zero-temperature
lattice parameter.
That's what you
would typically do.
Say, for a lithium, the lattice
parameter that you calculate,
this is in LDA, is 341.
And you get a bulk modulus
that's 15.4 gigapascal,
and experimentally
it's 11.6 just
like you expect it's too
stiff very typically in LDA--
same deal for the other metals
although for aluminum it's
not as bad.
OK.
Then you could say, well, I
remember what Sader taught me
in the lecture.
If I want to have the room
temperature bulk modulus,
all I need to do is calculate
the bulk modulus at the room
temperature by this constant.
So that's what this is.
So you take the room
temperature lattice constant.
You calculate the
curvature there.
And notice that now you're on
the other end of experiment.
OK?
And then you can
do something else.
You can do the full
blown thing and actually
try to find the
equilibrium-room-temperature
lattice parameter of your
LDA, which isn't necessarily
the real one.
Remember?
LDA will tend to
over-contract things
and calculate the
bulk modulus there,
and that's what you get here.
And, of course, this is better.
And it's sort of typical
because you're, in some sense,
working in a consistent
solution of the Hamiltonian.
You know, this is the minimum
the Hamiltonian gives you,
whereas at this
lattice parameter,
you're actually above
the real minimum.
And with this one,
you're actually below it.
So if you want to do
the full solution,
you would go and look
at the thermal expansion
to predict the
lattice parameter.
Well, how do you do
thermal expansion?
Well, remember where thermal
expansion comes from.
Thermal expansion comes
from essentially the volume
dependence of the free energy.
And that comes from two terms.
You have an energy
that's volume dependent,
and you have an entropy
that's volume dependent.
And the minimum
volume is obtained
by minimizing this with
respect to the volume.
There's another way
you can show where
thermal expansion comes from.
And here I have to brush
up my own thermal again,
but essentially you can show
that it comes from the volume
dependence that you can get
it from only this term--
from the volume dependence
of the entropy--
because the volume
dependence of the entropy.
Here, you can use all
this beautiful stuff
of Maxwell relations and,
et cetera, et cetera.
You can write this as
a chain derivative.
And so what you get is that
this is the compressibility
times the dv/dt.
And so dv/dt, this
is essentially
the thermal expansion.
And so what you see is, since
dp/dv is always positive,
pressure rises less
negative pressure
to get a smaller volume
and increase the pressure.
So the thermal expansion depends
on how the entropy changes
with volume.
So the critical part--
this is the hard
part-- is calculating
the entropy of the system
and, not just the entropy,
the entropy as a
function of volume.
And to calculate the
entropy is exactly
the same problem as
dealing with temperature
because the entropy
is essentially
counting the excitations
your system goes into.
And temperature is the average
energy of those excitations.
But so to get entropy is the
same problem as temperature.
You have to know
which excitations
you have to deal with, and you
have to have a model for them,
and you have to
equilibrate them.
OK.
Where will most of
that entropy come from?
Typically, we think of thermal
expansion largely caused
by vibrational entropy--
by phonon entropy.
So why does the entropy
go up with volume,
which is what gives
you thermal expansion?
Because if you
stretch the material,
the bonds get slightly softer.
So the vibrational
frequencies gets smaller.
They gets weaker.
The bonds get softer, so
you get more vibrations.
Or in a quantized
scheme, remember
that the spacing
between the zeroth level
of a phonon and the
first excited one
is h nu, h times the frequency.
So if the frequency
becomes smaller,
your first excited
state is closer.
So you excite more.
You have more disorders.
You have more entropy.
And that's why
most materials have
positive thermal expansion,
because essentially they
get softer as you stretch them.
So this is, for
example, for lithium,
the energy as a function of--
this is at room temperature--
as a function of volume.
So this would be the
room-temperature-equilibrium
lattice constant.
And this is the free energy
as a function of volume,
so this would be the
room-temperature-equilibrium
lattice constant.
OK.
We're not going to say
much about the sort
of subtle details about how you
calculate thermal expansion.
There is a sort of direct
assimilation approach,
and that will be
the next lecture.
So you could really just
do molecular dynamics,
which, again, we'll come to
later what that exactly means,
and equilibrate your cell size.
The other is to
go more explicitly
to a calculation of entropy
as a function of volume.
And so the way you would
calculate the entropy is
by calculating-- if you're only
going to deal with vibrational
entropy--
by calculating the
phonon density of states.
So literally you would look
at the quantized vibrations
through the statistical
mechanics on them.
And those of you have taken
320 may have sort of remembered
this and calculate the
free energy associated
with these phonons.
And I'll say a little
more about this later.
For example, this is a
phonon spectrum for silicon.
So you can actually quite
accurately calculate it.
Remember that to get the
thermal expansion it's not
enough to just phonons at
one volume, because you get
need to get the entropy
as a function of volume.
So at a few different volumes--
that means you really
have to do the phonons
at several different volumes
to get the thermal expansion
right.
This sort of looks hard,
but phonon calculations
have become quite routine.
They're very well developed.
There's, in some
cases, even, like,
codes that do it
almost semi automatic,
which it's typically done either
by a linear response technique
where you sort of
perturb a lattice really
by a phonon with
short wavelength,
so that you can really
calculate the energy of it.
So this is like setting up
a supercell with a phonon
in it is called a frozen
phonon approximation.
There are perturbation
techniques, linear response
techniques.
And then some people
do it in real space
by calculating force
constants and setting up
force constant
modulus for phonons.
So here's sort of
the result that you
would get in LDA and GGA for
copper with phonons only.
Again, the LDA number
and the GGA number
bracket the experiment,
but I would say, overall,
it seems to do very well.
Again, I think what
you see is the LDA
is a little on the stiff side.
The GGA is a little
on the soft side.
It's very typical for
these two in metals.
So the LDA expands
a little less.
The GGA expands a little more.
But, you know, if you sort
of look at the scale here,
it's pretty amazing that this
effect comes out quite well.
But what about other things?
Remember that the
thermal expansion comes
from how the entropy
changes with volume,
but that's the total entropy.
The calculation I
showed you only had
the vibrational entropy in it.
OK?
So any other level
of excitations
that changes with volume can
affect your thermal expansion.
And obvious one is the
electronic excitation.
So any time you're not
working on an insulator,
you will start getting
electronic excitations.
And can they change with volume?
And the answer is yes.
What I'm showing
you here is that--
and I must admit I forgot
which material this is,
which is really bad of me.
But I'm pretty sure
it's the metal.
So this is the ratio of the
electronic thermal expansion,
which is unfortunately
called beta here not
alpha, to the total extent
of thermal expansion--
the electronic plus
the vibrational one.
And so what you see
is only at very--
and this is on a reduced
temperature scale.
This is the temperature in
units of the Debye temperature.
Think of the Debye temperature
as sort of the temperature
scale at which the vibrations
become classical, which,
for a lot of
materials, it will be
somewhere in the order
of 200 to 500 Kelvin,
so it's not 1 Kelvin.
It's not a million Kelvin.
So what you see is only
at really low temperature
is the electronic
thermal expansion
important in these materials.
Now why is it so important here?
Anybody know?
It's actually because the
phonon one is really small.
Remember this is the
ratio of the two.
When you're at a
real low temperature,
the thermal expansion is
very small in general.
And the reason is
you're essentially
harmonic in your phonon
degrees of freedom.
So you have almost
no thermal expansion.
If you have fully
harmonic vibrations,
then the entropy does
not change with volume.
Because if you are
in a quadratic,
your curvature is
the same everywhere.
OK?
So your frequency is
the same everywhere.
Your phonon frequency
is the same,
so your entropy is
the same everywhere.
So at very low temperature,
you have almost no
phonon thermal expansion.
So the electronic one plays an
important role, but all of them
together are small anyway.
And here when you only at, say--
this is a logarithmic scale,
so let's say at roughly half
of the Debye temperature
the electronic effect
is almost meaningless.
That doesn't mean there are not
some esoteric materials where
it does become important.
There are some materials--
sort of complex oxides
typically where you can start
inducing valence fluctuations
at elevated temperature.
But even 300, 400 Kelvin.
And in oxides, if you change
the valence of an ion,
they sort of change size
because the orbitals
are very localized.
So there you can see a
substantial effect of electrons
on thermal expansion.
But in many cases we
wouldn't worry about it.
So that was the example
of thermal expansion.
So there you have to worry
about phonons, maybe electrons.
Here's another example where
you would absolutely need
a temperature-dependent study.
Here's the phase diagram
of titanium zirconium.
Titanium and zirconium are
both hexagonal close packed HCP
at low temperature.
At high temperature,
they're actually both BCC.
And so this is the
transition temperature
on the titanium side.
This is the
transition temperature
on the zirconium side.
Let's say you
wanted to know-- you
wanted to be able to predict
such transition temperatures.
So then you obviously need
to get the subtle energy
difference between HCP
titanium and BCC titanium
as a function of temperature.
So you need to know
what contributes
to the entropy of these phases.
And you could say,
well, you know,
I'm really good at
my initial stuff.
So I'm going to do ab-initio
molecular dynamics.
And again I'm running
a little bit ahead.
Molecular dynamics
is essentially
you let the atoms move according
to Newton's equation of motion.
So it's essentially doing
the vibrations of the atoms.
And if you do that,
essentially, you
include the vibrational
entropy in the system,
because you've included
the displacement of atoms
as your model for
thermal excitation.
So that's the same
as vibrations.
So would you get
that transition?
I mean, these are
questions you're
going to be faced with
as you apply modeling.
It's when you deal
with temperature
that it becomes
unfortunately rather
important to understand
the physics that
drives your phenomena.
So you can sort
make a blind choice.
So let's say our ab-initio
Hamiltonian was perfect,
like LDA or GGA had no errors.
And then we do
molecular dynamics,
so we let the atoms
kind of move around.
And we have infinite
computer time.
So we can sample long enough
and simulate long enough.
Would we get that?
I mean, the question
really translates to,
is that transition determined
by atomic vibrations?
Because that's the
excitation mode
you've allowed by doing
dynamics of atoms.
I don't know.
Do you know the answer?
I don't.
OK.
I'm giving you a topic here.
This is a hot topic of
discussion among people
who do alloy theory.
What drives these HCP to BCC
transitions, which are actually
very common in
metals or anything
close-packed at low temperature
to something less close-packed.
Most people will argue that
it is the atomic vibrations--
that it's essentially a
vibrational entropy difference.
OK?
The close-packed phase
tends to be stiffer.
The less closed phase
tends to be softer.
Remember softer means
lower frequencies.
Lower frequencies
means higher entropy.
Higher entropy means you become
favored at high temperature.
I know it's a lot of
steps to go through,
but if you've
never done thermal,
you should get this by now.
So if that's true, then
our perfect ab-initio MD
would get this transition.
OK?
But what about
other excitations?
There are some people who claim
that this is really driven
by electronic excitations,
because also BCC phases tend
to have higher
electronic entropy.
And I'll show in a
second why that is
and how you could
sort of know that.
If that's the case, then
you shouldn't get this right
just doing ab-initio MD.
Then you should start
explicitly including
the electronic
excitations, which can
be done in ab-initio methods.
But routinely it's
not done because it's
a pain in the butt.
And remember we often--
the problem is that,
as we do modeling,
we often tend to
make approximations
not because we can justify
them but because we don't know
how to do them differently.
We tend to make
approximations of convenience
sometimes rather
than justify them.
Here's another phase diagram.
You think the same deal.
Huh?
This is copper gold.
We just talked about
titanium zirconium,
and there it was
either vibrations
or electronic excitations.
Here it's totally-- it's
driven totally differently.
These are FCC phases
copper and gold.
And all these
compounds in between
are ordered FCC compounds,
so they're really
just ordering of copper and
gold items on the FCC lattice.
So this phase diagram is
completely driven by what we
call configurational entropy.
OK?
So it's by the
copper and the gold
interchanging sites
on the FCC lattice.
So if you wanted to model this
as a function of temperature,
you would need a model that
explicitly deals with that.
And the vibrations, for example,
may be much less important.
And actually they are
much less important
in setting the topology
of that diagram.
OK?
So different problems,
different physics.
And it's going to lead
to different models
for dealing with temperature.
And here's the ultimate one.
I thought that
this didn't exist.
For a long time, us alloy
theorists have wiped away
electronic entropy
because we just
don't know how to
deal with it, and we
don't like to deal with it.
So we write in paper saying
that it's not important,
but here's a system
that's completely
driven by electronic entropy.
Now agreed it's
slightly esoteric,
it's vanadium oxide
which undergoes
metal-insulator transitions.
This is its phase diagram.
And actually temperature
pressure space
since there's no
compositional axis,
it's a stoichiometric compound.
And at low temperature
and low pressure
it's an antiferromagnetic
insulator.
If you actually raise
the temperature,
it becomes metallic
and changes structure.
And it's completely driven by
the fact that, in the metal,
the entropy of the
electrons is higher than
in the antiferromagnetic
insulator.
So this is one of these
things that, again, let's
go back to our ab-initio MD.
Like, if it was
perfect, but all we
did was let the atoms vibrate,
we should not get this right.
OK?
And it's amazing some
people get it right,
but, if you have completely
the wrong physics
that you allow in
your model, there's
no reason you should get
the phase behavior right.
This one I like very much
because this is a topic
that many people deal with.
This is a problem
of interface energy.
This is simply calculating
the coherent interface
between silver and aluminum.
They're both FCC metals.
So you put them
together, and you
calculate the interface energy.
This is something
you very often need.
And so this is that
interface as a function
of-- interfacial energy as
a function of temperature.
And the two types of dots
are different interface
orientations.
And I forget.
I think one is a 1, 1, 1
plane and one is a 1, 0, 0.
But I'm not absolutely
sure, and I forgot
to put the reference data.
This is out of
Mark [INAUDIBLE]'s's
work in Northwestern.
But I'll put the
reference on when
I put the notes on the web.
So obviously the
interfacial energy
goes down with temperature.
OK?
And this is often
something you need
if you want to study wetting
and all that kind of cool stuff
and nucleation
problems and stuff.
So the question is, where does
that temperature dependence
come from?
Because we've already had
sort of three different types
of things induced
temperature phenomena.
So where does it come from here?
Because if you don't
know that, your modeling
is going to be irrelevant.
You can get a hint
from the fact that it's
getting really a lot
smaller with temperature
and actually kind of goes to 0.
What would happen to that
interface as you heat it up?
I think you know afraid to say.
Diffusion.
Yeah.
It interdiffusers.
Silver and aluminum are somewhat
immiscible at low temperature.
But when you heated up silver
and aluminum interdiffused,
they actually don't form a full
solid solution until your way
up, but they enter interdiffuse.
So essentially what's happening
to that interface, that's
sort of getting more diffuse.
On the silver side, you have
a lot more aluminum atoms.
And on the aluminum side, you
have a lot more silver atoms.
So it starts to look less
and less like an interface.
And actually by here
near the interface
you've reached almost
perfect solubility,
so that's why the
interface energy is 0.
So this is why--
it's because of the interdiffuse
that the interface energy
goes down.
OK?
So let's say that this was
experimental data that you'd
gotten.
If you had no idea about the
physics from that interface,
you would probably not
apply the right simulation.
Because if you took a hard
silver aluminum interface--
you know, pure silver,
pure aluminum--
and had all the beautiful
stuff, you know.
Temperature dependent, had
the vibrations, maybe even
the electronic excitations--
you will not even get
nearly close to the sensor,
because the decrease
in interface energy
with temperature is purely
driven by interdiffuse
in this case.
OK?
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
Or how is the [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Right.
It's not just configurational
entropy that's driving it up.
Well, how is it defined?
It's defined by looking at
the energy of the two pieces
together and then
the energy of the two
in the bulk with the same
driving chemical potentials.
It's a good question because
it is a little subtle,
because they're
both open systems.
That makes it a little subtle.
But what drives it is--
it's the configurational
entropy that disorder it.
But it's really the fact that--
it's really the
temperature dependence
of the interfacial energy.
Because they become
so disordered,
the energy of interaction
becomes almost nil--
the effective energy
of interaction--
because they basically look
the same on both sides.
You have effectively no
interaction energy left.
This is one that I
used to ask about.
This is a thermal
conductivity uranium oxide.
This is a really old result.
I have to find the reference.
This is one of the very
early simulation results.
That's why it's
on uranium oxide.
I think I've told
you this story.
Potential modeling in
oxide started in England
with the nuclear
industry, and they
thought it'd be good to do
this on nuclear materials.
So here's the calculated
thermal conductivity
as a function of
temperature, and I'll
tell you how to calculate this.
To calculate this-- literally
by doing a molecular dynamics
simulation looking
at essentially energy
transport through phonons.
And the way you have--
thermal expansion is caused
by phonons scattering.
You have a phonon going through.
And at some point, it needs
to sort of-- that wave packet
needs to become decoherent.
It's scattered, so it
can deliver its energy.
But essentially heat
conduction comes--
at least some form
of heat conduction
comes from phonon transport.
And that's what the calculated.
What's the brown curve?
And then the purple
curve of the experiment--
and you see something
kind of odd here.
There's obviously a whole
region of temperature
really good agreement.
If I'd written a paper,
I'd shown just that part.
But then suddenly above
2,000, the two really diverge.
And when you see
something like this,
it should always, like,
make a light on there.
The physics must be changing.
So uranium oxide
is an insulator.
The fluoride or antifluorite
structure, I think.
You're pretty high up
here 2,000 degrees.
What happens here
is that you start
getting an electronic
contribution
to the thermal conductivity.
When you start having
hot electrons--
essentially electrons
that can move--
they carry with
them thermal energy.
I mean, it's the basis of
the thermoelectric effect.
It's the Seebeck coefficient--
the Peltier coefficient.
So at high temperature,
you typically
see a contribution
of the electrons
to the thermal conductivity.
In most materials
at low temperature,
the electronic thermal
conductivity is small.
It's largely
dominated by phonons.
But in a lot of
materials it does start
to show up at high temperature.
And now what's high
and low depends
a little bit on whether you
have a metal or an insulator.
If you have a really
big bandgap insulator,
they will never show up
because you will never
have mobile electrons.
So that was kind of the intro
to set the stage that you have
to think of the excitations
that you want to deal with when
you work with temperature.
Now I was going
to sort of quickly
go through the two
big lines of approach,
and this is really a
kind of table of contents
for the rest of the course.
One approach is to
simulate dynamics.
And this is what I've
talked about before.
This is what's called
molecular dynamics.
And Professor Marzari
is going to lecture
on that for several lectures.
Essentially, it's
Newtonian motion for atoms.
You say you've got a
bunch of atoms together.
On each of them, I can
calculate the force
coming from the other ones.
Force is minus the
gradient of the energy.
So it's the derivative of
the energy with respect
to the positions of the atoms.
And then you say, you know,
I know Newton's equation
of motion.
Force tells me the
acceleration, so F equals ma.
So if I know the
force, I know how much
to accelerate that atom.
And so you
essentially keep track
of velocities of
atoms and positions,
and you do a
numerical integration
of the Newtonian
equations of motion.
That's all molecular
dynamics is.
And you do that a lot, a
lot, a lot, a lot of times.
So you track the
dynamics of atoms.
How do you set the temperature--
sort of a cool thing.
I mean, Professor
Marzari will go
into this in much more detail.
But the temperature
is essentially
the energy in your system.
But remember that Newtonian
dynamics is energy conserving.
So if you do your
Newtonian dynamics perfect,
then whatever energy you've
put in in the beginning
is whatever energy
you'll have at the end.
So the temperature
of your system
is determined by the
energy input you started.
And what people typically
do in simulations
is that, if it's not quite
right the way you started,
you sort of adjust it on the go.
You take out a
little bit of energy.
You put it back in if you want
to adjust the temperature.
Again, you'll hear a lot more
of that in the coming lectures.
And there are flavors
of this depending
on how you get your forces.
It's all the same
molecular dynamics.
But if you get your forces from
empirical potential models,
then it goes fast--
your force calculation--
because calculating the energy
in empirical potential is fast.
If you get it from
quantum mechanics,
then it's called ab-initio
molecular dynamics.
And then it's slower.
You have to get your forces
from quantum mechanics,
but it's the same molecular
dynamics essentially.
Oh.
So that's the first approach
to simulate the dynamics.
The other one, which
we'll also deal,
is to go through
statistical mechanics.
I mean, we sort of know
how to average over
microscopic degrees of freedom.
And that's what's statistical
mechanics tells us.
And in some cases that
will be more advantageous.
So you build some
approximate model
for the degrees of freedom.
You try to get the energetics
for those degrees of freedom.
And then rather
than simulating, you
sort of do some more analytical
or numerical integration
of them and get,
say, temperature
dependent properties.
And we'll show
you that as well--
how to do that.
So you can kind of see that this
is what we're going to cover.
I just wanted to give you
perspective on what's coming.
The sort of first piece here,
this is a direct simulation.
We do molecular dynamics.
And then the rest here,
kind of largely this piece,
is sort of more, I
would say, stat mech
and making relevant models
for your degrees of freedom
that are not obtainable
by direct simulation.
And then this, the
rest here, is kind
of a bunch of case studies
and separate applications.
OK.
I wanted to get out of
this and show you a movie.
So here's a molecular dynamic
simulation of a planetary gear.
I don't know if you've
ever seen this one.
It's one of the
totally crazy ones.
So somebody had the idea
that you could make--
in the world of nano, you
could make a nano gear.
So these are
actually molecules--
let me run it again.
You see the molecules in
the center turn faster,
and they kind of rotate
over the other ones.
And the outer
circle runs slower.
And this is done by solving
Newton's equations of motion
essentially for these molecules.
I'll show you one more.
No, it's not the right one.
Oh, here we go.
This is buckyballs shot
onto a silicon surface.
So you can sort of
see they kind of--
some stick.
Some get shot at it.
Some stick, and
some bounce back up.
And they kind of vibrate
on the silicon surface.
And so this is all done
simply by integrating
Newton's equation of motion.
From
OK.
Let me go back to the lecture
before you get totally enamored
by the movies.
OK.
I'm going to say a
little bit about sort
of which route to go when you
want to deal with temperature.
You know, an obvious
way is always
to do the direct dynamics
through molecular dynamics.
It's a powerful approach.
It's, in particular,
powerful to see phenomena
that you didn't even know were
there, because in almost all
the other approximate approaches
we're going to do for dynamics
or temperature, we're going
to assume that we know
and understand the phenomena
that are responsible
for the macroscopic
behavior we see.
In some sense,
molecular dynamics
is the only way where
you don't presume much.
I mean, you presume something
about your Hamiltonian,
your energy function.
But otherwise, you just
kind of let the system run,
and you see what happens.
What you have to keep
in mind, of course,
is that the timescale over which
you run is extremely short.
I mean, you're now living on
the time in the world of atoms.
And atoms vibrate, let's say,
somewhere between 1 terahertz
maybe 10 terahertz.
That's actually pretty high--
10 terahertz.
So that would be 10 to
the 13 times per second.
And remember you have to
integrate equations of motion.
So think of an atom
vibrating in some well
or against another atom.
You probably need at least
10 discretization steps
along that one vibration.
So your time step is
of the order of 10
to the minus 15 seconds--
10 to the 14 seconds.
That's sort of the
order of magnitude.
For different materials
and different algorithms,
it will be different.
That's 10 femtoseconds.
So you have to kind of do
an iteration step every 10
femtoseconds.
So that means even if you
do 100,000 time steps,
you still only have
1 nanosecond of time.
OK?
And so you'll see typical--
and these simulations are
in the order of picoseconds
to 100 nanoseconds.
Those are really
long simulations.
And it's amazing, but you can
see a lot of important physics
recurring on that
timescale-- sometimes
the reaction between molecules
or absorption resorption
phenomena.
If you sort of want to do, and
the first thing you should do
is a back-of-the-envelope
calculation is the phenomenon
that I want to see,
or that I hope to see,
does it live anywhere
near this time scale?
And sometimes you can
give the system help.
You can raise the
temperature, because stuff
will happen faster.
But you should
realize that there's
certain stuff that you do not
see on this time scale at all.
There are people who
study solidification out
of liquids within d.
And, you know, there
may be even some here.
It's stupid period.
You do not see anything
relevant on this time
scale that has to do with
any real solidification.
The only thing you can do is
enormously super cool a liquid,
overdrive it, and
really sort of induce
extremely fast crystallization
which has nothing
to do with real solidification.
And so the one example I
give is diffusion in solids.
You can do dynamics
on fast diffusers,
but most things are
not fast diffusers.
So I did a--
I show you the kind of
back-of-the-envelope
calculation you should do.
A diffusivity is a
length scale squared
times the jump rate,
where a is essentially
the distance which you jump.
OK?
So if you take a relatively fast
diffusion at room temperature
10 to the minus 14 centimeters
squared per second,
it's a respectable diffusivity
at room temperature.
Most materials, you
would never see that.
It's not quite a
fast diffuser yet.
This number would be more
at 10 to the minus 11, 10
to the minus 12.
And you take a jump
length of 1 Angstrom.
So that's 10 miles
18 centimeter.
Then you can show that the jump
rate is about 100 per second.
So if you have a 10 to
the minus 14 diffusivity,
an atom jumps about 100 times
per second, or about 1 times
per 10 milliseconds.
So do you see now the
enormous disparity
in time scale from 1
nanosecond to 10 milliseconds?
So you could wait forever in
your dynamics to see things
if you're sort of not smart.
You'll see similar phenomena.
Like, you could study.
You could use dynamics to look
at, say, surface deposition.
Let's say molecular beam
epitaxy or something
like that where you lay
down layer by later.
If you actually do the math
in a real MB experiment,
you tend to lay down about
one layer per second.
That's the order of magnitude.
So you can actually never get
that by direct simulation.
So what do people do?
Well, people do the
short simulations
to extract useful information
that they can then
use in other models
to get the real time
scales that they want.
And so that's some of the
things we're going to teach you.
OK.
Probably going to
run out of time here.
But the other option--
so if you don't.
If you cannot do the dynamics--
is to use statistical
mechanics and sort of
integrate as far of the
length scale and time scale
as you can.
And just those of you
who may have never seen
statistical mechanics, I'm going
to now totally confuse you.
But the essential ideas are
sort of in these four equations
that you now consider
a macroscopic state
as a collection of
microscopic states
that you can
fluctuate in between.
The probability for each
of these microscopic states
is proportional to the
exponential of minus beta
that the energy, and
beta is 1 over kT.
So what does that mean?
Microscopic states
with low energy
show up with high probability,
and microscopic stage
with high energy shell up with
with very low probability.
Makes sense.
The sum of all
these unnormalized
probability terms is called
the partition function.
And you can show that knowledge
of the partition function
is exactly the same as
knowledge of the free energy.
The free energy is
essentially the logarithm
of the partition function.
And the entropy is the product
of the probability times
the log of the probability
summed over these things.
And again, that makes
sense because if you
are in one microscopic
state, then pi
is 1 for that micro state
and 0 for all the other ones.
So 1 log 1 0.
And 0 log 0 is also 0.
So your entropy is 0.
So you have no disorder.
So if your macroscopic
state leads
to only one microscopic
realization that you can beam,
then you have zero entropy.
It's when you can be in multiple
different microscopic states
that you have entropy.
So you can think of
atomic vibrations,
for example, as
really going between
different microscopic states
of the positions of the atoms.
You can think of
electronic entropy
as going between different
electronic microscopic states.
OK.
So I want to show
you one example
and probably end with that.
Electronic entropy.
It's one that, on
the face of it,
looks very difficult
to deal with,
because you have to deal
with the excitations
of the electron.
But actually in many cases it's
much easier than you think.
If you solve the
Kohn-Sham equations,
you get the eigenstates i and
the eigenvalues for the energy.
And typically we
tend to treat these
as one electron eigenstates.
So we sort of fill--
we think of filling these
with an electron, where
we have a bunch of them,
and we fill them up
to the Fermi level.
There's actually nothing in
the theory of density function
that tells you that they are
one-electron eigenstates where
we treat them like that.
So if you think of--
I have a bunch of.
Let's say I draw them
as discrete levels,
a bunch of energy levels--
E1, E2.
And, of course, in
a solid, this will
become a density of states.
What's the level of uncertainty?
What do I need to
know to characterize
my electronic configuration?
All I need to know is, is
the level occupied or not?
So I can characterize
my electronic state
by saying which levels
are occupied or not.
So if you do this
on a solid now where
you have a real density
of states-- and I've
shown you one here.
So this is a density
of electron states.
This is energy.
And forget the
bottom piece here.
Just think of the top.
These are actually
spin polarized.
One is in the up dos,
and one is the down dos.
So my Fermi level--
I don't know.
It's actually at 0 here, but
that makes it less interesting.
Let me assume the Fermi
level is at minus 2 here.
So at 0 temperature
I feel all the states
below the Fermi level.
OK?
At elevated temperature, you
know you apply the Fermi-Dirac
distribution function,
and so you'll
have a filling that's
maybe a little different.
And I'm kind of exaggerating.
The width of the Fermi-Dirac
distribution function is not
nearly--
so it's 1 here and 0 here.
It's not nearly as wide
at reasonable temperature.
So how can you get the entropy?
Well, you can get the
entropy from the probability
that each electronic state
is filled or unfilled.
OK?
So if f is the probability
that it's filled--
so this is the entropy coming
from when the state is filled,
the entropy coming from
when the state is unfiled,
and the sum over all
these possibilities
is the electronic entropy.
So if, in ab-initio calculation,
you calculate the density
of states, you actually have
a trivial way of getting out
the electronic entropy.
And this is-- getting
the density of states
is really rather simple.
So you just smear it with
the Fermi-Dirac distribution
function, and you sum--
or you do this as an integral
typically rather than summing.
And you have the
electronic entropy.
It's very simple to do.
So just as sort of a caution,
what I should tell you
is that usually this
works very well,
but the fundamental
underlying approximation
lies in the starting point.
It's in assuming
that the epsilon I's,
or the eigenvalues,
are the eigenstates
of the real electron system.
So what I'm
essentially saying is
that if you excite an
electron or remove one
from the occupied states,
you're essentially
perturbing the system exactly
by that energy of that state
that I took out.
If I have a Kohn-Sham
eigenvalue of 3 electron
volts with some eigenstate, and
I put the electron in there,
I'm assuming that that's
exactly the perturbation
that a real electron
will do in the system.
If you go back at the
theory of density function,
there is nothing
in the theory that
tells you that that's right.
OK?
Remember density function
theory is based on the density?
And the Kohn-Sham idea was
essentially the smart way
of writing the density in terms
of things that look like one
electron orbital
but they aren't.
OK?
So an eigenstate
densely function theory
is not a one-electron orbit.
We just hope it is, and it
sometimes looks like it is.
But it's not.
And if it's not, then you
can describe excitations
of electrons as going between
one Kohn-Sham eigenstate
to another Kohn-Sham
eigenstate because they're not
one electron eigenstate.
OK?
So what we are doing
is completely hokey.
It's just that, in reasonable
materials and metals
and semiconductors,
they don't look
very much like
one-election eigenstate,
and this stuff works.
Where it breaks
down is typically
in materials with very high
degrees of correlation,
transition metal oxides, where
these things don't look at all
like one-electron eigenstates.
Because what happens in
those is, as soon as you
do an electron excitation, the
whole underlying eigenvalue
spectrum changes.
OK?
And remember then it's
not an eigenstate.
An eigenstate is supposed to
be orthogonal to the rest.
So if filling or
unfilling it changes
the occupation of
all the other ones
and the wave function
of all the other ones,
then it wasn't an eigenstate.
So there this stuff fails.
I'm kind of out of time.
So what I was going
to do was show you
the next picture, which you
may just have a look at.
It shows just the contribution
of the electronic entropy
and the vibration
entropy in metals
as a function of temperature,
so you can sort of
see how they compare
to each other.
So actually let me end here.
And we'll see you
back on Tuesday.